welcome to my model lifestyle channel
my
name is Daniel Maritz and in this video
I'm gonna talk about how to get a good
model portfolio
If you have not subscribed
yet. Please subscribe so you can see some
new and upcoming videos
so let's get
into this
all right guys so what is a model
portfolio?
well a model portfolio is
basically your best pictures that you can
show to the client so that they can book
you for jobs
that's basically it
but let's get into this a little bit
more.
you might get a book like this
This is my model portfolio
I'm from South
Africa and my mother agency is boss
models
now this is their book and what
you do is you take one of these books
You go to the casting and you show it
to the client and a client look through
your book and they see what kind of
model you are
now I'm more of a
commercial type of model which is more
smiling more natural
You can see it in the photos
and they go through these pictures
and they see basically the experience
that you have as a model
and they book
you based on your portfolio but also how
you appear to them in the castings
and how you fit their clothes
so the
model portfolio is very very important
to get jobs. The better your model portfolio is
the better chances you have for better and more jobs
So how do you get a good model portfolio?
well if you're
a beginner number one you have to do it
as many test shoots as you possibly can
the quicker you get a better portfolio
set up together the better chances you
have to get good modeling jobs
how do you get test shoots?
well your
agency can probably help you with that
they have the contacts. They just set up  a test shoot and that's how you start to get
pictures.
now the pictures that you have
to focus on first is you have to get at
least a good headshot
it's very very important
then you also
need some picture that shows off your
body
then you can bring in different
styles you can bring in the business
kind of clothes, suit  clothes and you
can bring in sport clothes.
varieties key
you have to give different angles as
well. look in the mirror and see which
sides of your face looks the best is it
the left? is it the right?
then which
side the smiles you know from the camera
straight from the camera to the left or
the right
so look and practice.
Also your frowns: you have different frowns
look at the mirror, practice a little bit
and see what is really good so that when
you do the test shoots you can give a
variety of expressions, variety of poses
and a variety of angles that you do in
front of the camera
all right so you do the
test shoots. So after you've done a couple
of test shoots, you would be able to go to
some castings and hopefully you can book
some jobs
so at the beginning you need
to do a lot of test shoots, right then
as you start getting jobs, you'll start
to get more and more pictures, but
getting new pictures will never stop
this is something that you will
continually do - as a model even if
you're experienced it doesn't matter you
need to continually update your book so
that it corresponds with your age and
also with your experience
alright guys so now you know how to get a good model
portfolio
thank you for checking the
video please subscribe if you liked the
video and also if you want to know more
about modeling well
I have added my
model course in the description where I
give you all my best tips that I have
learned over the last 10 years of being
a male model
see you in the next video